this video was brought to you by magic
spoon
what's up everybody helen here to talk
about the prettiest strangest people on
earth actors and i don't know if you
know this but sometimes actors do super
wild things for their craft sometimes
it's learning to ice skate sometimes
it's sewing a thousand-year-old egyptian
artifacts into their costumes but
sometimes if they're a student of method
acting it's dropping a dead pig in a
mailbox well that's what it includes if
you're jared leto letta was once a
critical and commercial darling earning
a claim for his performances and requiem
for a dream and dallas buyer's club but
in recent years his public persona has
felt less wedded to his acting and more
to the antics surrounding his
increasingly abysmal performances nobody
has ever said that to me nobody most
recently in the two-time box office flop
morbius so how did leto lose his way and
is his use or misuse of method acting
techniques bringing hollywood down with
him let's find out in this wisecrack
edition method acting what went wrong
but before we get into it i'm going to
take a break to have some magic spoon
cereal magic spoon puts all the fun
flavors of your childhood favorites into
sophisticated cereals that are good for
you too they're keto friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free and
low-carb plus there are zero grams of
sugar about 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each 140
calorie serving my personal favorite
magic spoon flavor is cookies and cream
but you can also try a bunch of other
flavors like cocoa fruity cinnamon roll
peanut butter frosted blueberry muffin
and maple waffle plus fan favorite
flavor honey nut has joined the
permanent collection too also quick note
honey nut does contain one gram of sugar
per serving if you're ready to try it
for yourself click the link below to
order magic spoon cereal today you can
build a custom variety box and if you
use the code wisecrack you can get five
dollars off and with magic spoon's 100
happiness guarantee there's no reason to
not give it a try today go ahead and
click the link below to get five dollars
off or go to magicspoon.com wisecrack to
save five dollars on your order today oh
and great news for our viewers in canada
and the uk magic spoon now ships to you
too
now back to the show if you're a movie
buff you've probably heard about letto's
preferred style of acting known as the
method and it's worth examining what
method acting actually is today the term
is basically synonymous with an actor
immersing themselves so deeply in their
character that all distinction
functionally disappears like daniel day
lewis refusing to shower while filming
the crucible or christian bale basically
starving himself for the machinist or
adrien brody nuking his entire personal
life for the pianist but while this
style of acting gets a lot of publicity
it has very little to do with method
acting as it was initially conceived the
term the method was created by russian
acting teacher and scholar constantine
stanislavski who believed in tyri
chavanier or living apart he thought
actors should depict life in all its raw
truth to that end he argued that they
should incorporate their own lived
experiences into their performances via
emotional memory that is all the
sensations emotions and physical
experiences you had acquired over the
course of your life which you could turn
on to bring greater truth to a scene it
required his students to use the full
extent of their physicality and
psychology and encourage them to think
deeply about their character's
motivation in any given scene every
movement you made should serve that
motivation and if channeled correctly he
believed this could create a truly
transcendent performance one in which
the audience might very well forget
they're watching a performance at all
method acting would later be adopted by
american acting instructors like lee
strasberg and stella adler though they
disagree on its meaning strasbourg
emphasized psychology and tapping into
effective memory via techniques like
improvisation adler in contrast evolved
the craft from primarily relying on
personal lived experiences to
prioritizing extensive research and
using imagination to immerse the actor
in the given circumstances of a role
this was in contrast to what was going
on in hollywood where silent film stars
had learned to compensate for their
silence through exaggerated motions and
facial expressions dramatic actors
behave more like dancers while comedians
like charlie chaplin or buster keaton
pulled from traditions like vaudeville
to create visual comedy that didn't need
sound to be funny by the time takis
rolled around in the late 1920s film
performance had been solidified in its
abstractness and realism wasn't even
desirable what's more hollywood had
consolidated its dominance over national
cinema and its burgeoning studio system
had established tight control over every
creative choice that went into
filmmaking including acting techniques
if naturalism in silent film was
functionally impossible once they turned
the mics on it was considered downright
unprofessional acting natural for the
camera didn't strike anybody as
particularly impressive so actors turned
it on the most successful ones patenting
a particular character to establish
their star power think humphrey bogart's
world weariness or katherine hepburn's
airy quips and icy stairs through
typecasting actors were differentiated
as products for example when jimmy
stewart repeated the same sweet natured
optimist performance he was reliably
delivering a product as only he could
hollywood rumbled along like this for a
couple decades and americans seemed cool
with it that is until a streetcar named
desire hit theaters you can't overstate
the impact of marlon brando whose
performance style ushered in many of the
greats from james dean to sidney poitier
and meryl streep the reason for brando's
sudden acclaim is simple he was one of
the first americans to use the method
while carrie grant was preoccupied with
acting like well cary grant brando was
preoccupied with capturing the unique
essence of each character both
internally and externally you don't
understand i could've had class
i could have been a contender
i could have been somebody
brando's acting was certainly in a
league of its own but of course in this
league there was crying in baseball
but he was also the right man at the
right time just as he was emerging
hollywood was undergoing a mid-century
shift in the kinds of male characters it
put on screen this meant moving away
from suave actors trading on their star
power and towards characters who were
rugged angry miserable cruel and
anti-social to the bone it's no surprise
that some scholars attribute this trend
to a need to express the collective pain
and trauma american men had experienced
over the course of two world wars
brandel was the perfect avatar for the
very real collective suffering americans
had endured but method acting wasn't
just about capturing the zeitgeist in
addition to facilitating more
naturalistic performances it also gave
actors a greater degree of authorship
over the work when creating his own
backstories internal monologues and
emotional experiences an actor like
brando was significantly adding to and
sometimes even changing the script
brando would even rewrite now iconic
lines to make them feel more natural
instead you come into my house on the
day my daughters to be married and you
asked me to do murder
money
note the way he gently cradles the cat
as he plans a brutal hit and that cat
wasn't even in the script this mother
but some actors inspired by brando's
method acting struggled with turning
their character on and off at wynn and
in the 1980s robert de niro found a
solution with his breakthrough
oscar-winning performance in raging bull
in which he played a troubled former
boxer
for the role he gained 60 pounds and did
in-depth research about the italian
immigrant experience most notably though
he also stayed in character for the
duration of production did this make him
miserable to work with well his co-star
catherine moriarty says that it was
scary to see him that way but that she
had complete trust in him and never felt
unsafe so had de niro taken the method
to the next level not according to
instructor strasberg who railed against
his approach he said our technique is
designed to be engaged and then stopped
you don't continue the reality he added
there is a fascination with staying in
character it is an anxious act used by
actors who don't have the confidence to
go in and out of character he contends
that if you are committed you can pick
it back up if we were to draw a graph of
my process of
my method
something like this so ian's ian's in
action
you shall not pass cut
sit here and sit here and sit here
okay say what you will about marlon
brando but by all accounts he was able
to turn off his role at night and enjoy
a bowl of pasta and de niro's extreme
interpretation or bastardization of
method acting would define the term
going forward today when you think of
going method you might think of daniel
day lewis refusing to move his body
while shooting my left foot forcing the
crew to push him around in a wheelchair
in search of greater authenticity while
in production on gangs of new york day
lewis wore only period appropriate
attire on and offset and subsequently
caught pneumonia this made for great
publicity but it also contributed to the
actor's status as a legend someone who
would sacrifice anything in his quest to
give an authentic performance it's also
rumored that he had a huge dispute with
paul thomas anderson while filming there
will be blood because day lewis wanted
to quote kill paul dano for realsies all
of which brings us back to leto now leto
has been going method since his early
days playing a heroin addict in requiem
for that he lost 26 pounds lived on the
street and stopped having sex so he
would share the constant cravings of his
character which i think implies he was
as addicted to sex as a heroin user is
addicted to heroin which is
dark the resulting performance was
widely acclaimed for dallas spire's club
he dropped 30 pounds and stayed in
character for the duration of the shoot
resulting in a performance that landed
him an oscar but popular opinion on the
actors started to turn and we'd be
remiss if we didn't point out that at
least some of the litto backlash stems
from credible allegations of sexual
assault made against the actor which in
and of itself is reason to really not
like the guy but opinions about his
acting abilities have also been on the
decline lately probably due to his
widely publicized antics on the set of
suicide squad during production leto
allegedly treated his co-stars
abominably sending them bizarre gifts
such as a used condom a live rat bullets
and anal beads after saying so himself
in a red carpet interview leto has since
denied these gifts but this isn't the
first time a movie star has been guilty
of disruptive on set behavior though
sometimes such behavior is rather
delightful george clooney is known for
pulling deliciously devious pranks and
everybody on set has fun however what
made letto's antics so unique was his
justification for them he was trying to
go full method and guess what it totally
worked i am not someone who is
love
i'm an idea
uh yeah so in this case leto's
commitment to the method doesn't seem to
have helped him craft a deeper or more
nuanced character you don't get the
sense that he's carefully drawing on
emotional memories whether his own or
those he's imagined for his character
his antics mostly just seemed to have
pissed off his co-workers he had a
henchman who would come into the
rehearsal room and the henchman came in
with a dead pig
and plopped it on the table
and then he walked out and that was our
introduction into jared leto in response
to criticism of his behavior he said i'm
an artist at the end of the day if i do
something risky and you don't like it
basically you can kiss my ass ah the old
i'm an artist so there aren't
consequences to my behavior excuse
fantastic and very original and we think
this response reveals a lot about what
method acting has become in its early
days it was about introspection
connecting more deeply to yourself and
thus to your character but these days
it's been popularized in the form of
loud outlandish stunts none more
important than doing crazy [ __ ] to your
body by these standards it seems like
stevo and johnny knoxville are the
method actors of our time indeed in
recent years the term method has become
a catch-all to articulate the courageous
ends actors will go to because these
days it's not enough to just stay in
character for the whole production see
we are a rather superficial species so
we often focus more on actors external
transformations rather than any internal
emotional work they're doing this has
been exemplified in recent years by
oscar baiting performances like natalie
portman in black swan or joaquin phoenix
and joker or heath ledger in the dark
knight what is it with dudes who play
joker this process is what scholar kevin
esch calls actorly transformation which
entails two things
one transforming your body for a role
and two doing so exclusively for greater
fidelity of performance rather than to
look a certain way indeed these bodily
transformations are often in service of
constructing a character that is ugly or
revolting these performances garnered
the most acclaim presumably because we
see these actors as brave for
sacrificing their most prized possession
their superhuman hotness esk argues that
this perception leads us to overvalue
such performances simply for their
physical fidelity did we mention that
people can be a little superficial
sometimes but it's not just about looks
modern method is also rife with
outrageous antics exemplified by folks
like leto or say leo who at least to his
credit typically goes method for movies
that are actually good take dicaprio
slicing his hand open during django
unchained that's right he bled real
blood supposedly cementing his complete
immersion in the role but leo hit the
peak of actually self-flagellation in
the revenant this man deliberately chose
to submerge himself in freezing waters
and eat raw bison liver in order to win
his first oscar and his win sent a
simple message a real actor destroys
themselves for their art which is why i
drink a tiny teaspoon of poison before
shooting every wisecrack video arguably
the revenant is far from dicaprio's best
performance but it certainly was the
most publicity generating this furthers
our suspicion that publicity rather than
elevation of acting as a craft has
become the point of this distorted
version of method acting and hardcore
method actors don't only risk harming
their own bodies even brando infamously
took method acting too far while filming
last tango in paris though it was made
before the job intimacy coordinator
existed surprising your co-star with
unplanned sexual contact is tantamount
to assault and brando's not the only
actor who's harmed a co-star in the name
of method acting take dustin hoffman
slapping meryl streep in kremer vs
kramer or jamie dornan preparing to play
a serial killer by actually stalking
random women who definitely were not
thanked in the credits sheesh dude as a
result of the emphasis on physical
transformation and outrageous stunts
critics and audiences have become more
primed to appreciate the torment and
extremes the actor went through as
opposed to the quality of the
performance itself this type of
appreciation demands a dual perspective
from viewers one that requires them to
be simultaneously invested in the
fantasy of the film while also being
hyper aware that they're watching an
actor at work and the most outrageous
thing about this besides the hassle of
sourcing bison liver is that it goes
against everything that method acting
was meant to be in the first place
method was about transcendence about
losing sight of the difference between
the actor and the character when it
becomes fuel for media frenzy all we do
is hyper focus on the actor doing the
role leo didn't disappear into his
character in the revenant if anything
the character disappeared into his
awesome star power the only role playing
going on was that of leo as strong man
who suffers for art so what makes leo's
work revelatory and letos work a
punchline well perhaps it's because
leto's forcing that type of intensity
upon others and doing so for low stakes
blockbusters rather than prestige films
while daniel day-lewis probably smelled
awful on the set of the crucible he
still had to bear the brunt of his
acting choices and when leo cut his hand
he dealt with the scar not his
co-workers however in an era where we're
learning to interrogate the filmmaking
practices of those in power jared leto
variously inconveniencing or straight up
terrorizing others in the name of acting
seems pretty unappealing margot opened
the box and there was a live rat
in the box for example on the set of
morbius they had to ask leto to stop
using crutches to use the bathroom and
use a wheelchair instead as his
commitment to method urination was
putting them behind schedule despite its
glamorization acting is still at the end
of the day a job and like any job there
should be a baseline of acceptable
behavior and acceptable sacrifice if
being a dick to her administrative
assistant was part of your accountant's
process you'd probably switch to turbo
tax but when an actor behaves like a
dick to get into character it's often
seen as proof of their dedication to
their craft what's more we don't expect
most professionals to endure ongoing
physical pain or emotional torment just
to be good at their jobs but because the
suffering artist trope is so prominent
we valorize great art being created out
of pain as a type of spiritual mystical
endeavor and method has become the
easiest way to measure that pain so is
method acting dead and did jared leto
kill it by being an [ __ ] or has
method just become a blanket excuse to
be an [ __ ] fellow method dabbler
robert pattinson suspects as such
explaining that you only ever see people
do the method when they're playing an
[ __ ] you never see someone being
lovely to everyone while they're really
deep in character and while that may be
functionally true we'd argue that the
method as originally conceived is alive
and well if perhaps not given the bulk
of critical attention for example
rosamond pike who famously portrayed amy
in gone girl subscribes to method acting
but not the full emergent of some of its
more extreme adherence she says during
the making of a film there are two
people living side by side there is you
and there is the character as you become
more and more familiar in that
character's head space and shoes you
become more deft at being able to switch
in and out but at the beginning you
always need a way in to get into amy's
head she made a special music playlist
for another role she would shadowbox in
between takes while playing amy she
tried to channel the character's
narcissism constantly asking herself
what effect am i having on this person
are they liking me are they impressed by
me watching her in gone girl you can
sense her doing what s stanislavski
instructed actors to do turning
remembered feelings into poetry
interestingly enough the ongoing
conflict between youthful dedication to
method's more extreme antics compared to
the quiet focus of experienced acting is
best embodied today in the discourse
about succession actors brian cox and
jeremy strong strong's approach to
acting was profiled in a viral new
yorker piece and though he identifies as
immersive rather than method he seems to
employ a lot of the same techniques for
example he distances himself from his
co-stars to mimic his character's
strained relations and requested to get
actually tear gassed in a scene just for
the authenticity cox a classically
trained scottish actor finds this
approach concerning calling method
acting an american disease he personally
ascribes to a turn it on turn it off
style of acting that frankly sounds a
lot less miserable so is it time to
abandon method acting maybe for the
jared letos of the world on a small
scale leto is no different than anyone
who thinks their job is important enough
to justify making their co-workers lives
miserable his problem is less that he's
taking method too far and more that he's
just being a jerk and all the attention
he gets for doing so undermines the
actors who can use method to carefully
craft psychologically rich performances
overall it seems to us that a technique
invented to facilitate more authentic
performances is now overwhelmingly
drawing attention to the actor as a
performer rather than as a character of
course method acting can still be used
to add quiet truth to a skilled actor's
work our spirits live on in the
whole of time
exist in many vessels
through time that just doesn't make for
the spiciest entertainment weekly
headline but we'd like to give the last
word to sir lawrence olivier who after
learning that his co-star and marathon
man dustin hoffman had gone three days
without sleeping to get into character
allegedly asked my dear boy why don't
you just try acting but what do you guys
think does modern method acting need to
smoke and or touch some grass is jared
leto spoiling method acting for everyone
else or is fully submerging yourself and
your character still the best way to
achieve an authentic on-screen
performance let us know in the comments
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out the new
perks on our jazzed up patreon page gnaw
on that subscribe button like get some
delicious bison liver and don't forget
to ring that bell and as always thanks
for watching
later
[Music]
you